I posted a video yesterday that got a
lot of good feedback as a video covering
the immortal zuzuong game and at the end
of the video I mentioned that I'm toying
with idea of making a new series
covering chess games that everyone
should know and I thought I'll continue
the trend with this video and share a
game that left a pretty big impression
on Me Maybe about 15 years ago maybe
more I forget the exact time I saw this
game for the first time but there is
something special about this game which
uh is related to something that happened
to me recently which we will get to but
in this video I want to share a really
really cool game between Paul morphe and
Lewis Paulson it was played in 1857 so
over 150 years ago but the great thing
about classic games like this they're
Evergreen and there's still so many
lessons to take away from the old games
and it's also interesting to see how the
modern engines react to these games as
well so I'll share a few moments where
sockfish will have some pretty cool
insights but let's get into it uh morphe
was playing black and there is a reason
we are looking from the back side it
started with a Four Knights and Bishop
to B5 now I've seen this position happen
a lot in like Scholastic level chess and
beginner chess and there's a very common
mistake a slight mistake that white will
make here if Bishop C4 this allows the
center fork trick with Knight takes E4
takes and D5 and this is considered to
be good for black and the reason why I'm
showing this line is because something
similar happened in this game but kind
of with reverse colors white played
Bishop B5 here morphe played Bishop C5
after castle castle White went for the
same tactical trick with Knight takes E5
temporarily second in the night and if
black takes back then D4 and white is uh
is regaining the piece and also taking
over the center
so rather than taking the knights morphe
played the move Rook to E8 which is very
logical just pressuring the knights and
then eventually trying to win the pawn
and after takes takes Bishop C4 is
played and a position was reached in
which black has a few options now the
most obvious looking move is Knight
takes E4 but as black If You're Gonna
Play this move you have to see what
whites can do in response and I believe
this move would be a blunder after takes
takes takes there's a really nice tactic
for whites feel free to pause the video
if you want to try and find it but the
move is Bishop takes F7 which is a
pretty devastating blow after King takes
F7 not Queen H5 which would win the
bishop but even stronger Queen F3
winning the rook and uh yeah black is
going to be down a lot of material and
losing here so it's important not to
rush with taking the pawn
and the move that morphe played in the
game looks like one of the best moves a
pawn to B5 chasing back the bishop and
then uh later trying to regain the pawn
it turns out that there's an even
stronger move here for black and I
wasn't aware of this Improvement until
analyzing the scheme right before the
recording and stockfish actually
suggests a really really powerful idea
which I'm actually surprised that morphe
didn't play because it's a very morphe
like attacking move and one cool thing
about this position it's very
reminiscent of a Stafford Gambit this is
essentially the same structure you get
in the Safford maybe some small
difference with black having castled and
having The Rook on Yates but the move
that black can play here is very typical
for Stafford Gambit type position Knight
to G4 and it turns out that this move is
actually considered to be winning for
black at least according to stockfish
because threats are just unbearable
against White's position first of all
Queen H4 is a deadly threat threatening
H2 and F2 but not only that black is
threatening to take on F2 right away if
we just imagine each three Knight F2
Rook F2 Bishop F2 and then Queen D4 and
end picking up the loose bishop and uh
yeah black is up material after all said
and done
so I was analyzing a bit and uh yeah
white doesn't have like a great defense
like D3 runs into Queen H4 uh there's a
line Queen F3 which looks useful
defending and attacking but this runs
into Knight E5 defending attacking
attacking essentially forcing Queen E2
but then Bishop G4 and white would be
pretty much toast given that the queen
is tied down to defending the bishop
there's no F3 because the pawn is pinned
and black is winning material here
so it was a little bit sad that morphe
didn't go for Knight G4 may have led to
a easier win but um the move that was
played was Pawn V5 hitting the bishop
provoking Bishop E2 and then the pawn
can safely be captured there's no
counter tactics for white here and after
takes takes it looks like a relatively
peaceful position a white played Bishop
F3 Rook E6 it's equal material but it's
still a little bit uncomfortable for
whites because black is a hen
development and white would really like
to play D4 to just control the center
and hit the bishop and for that reason
white played Pawn C3
Now Pawn C3 I think was maybe the the
beginning of White's downfall uh what
white should have done was just play
Pawn D3 and try and develop a bishop and
just complete development but upon C3
opens up a really nice opportunity for
black given that white wants to play D4
next move black can prevent this with
Queen to D3
and one of the reasons why I'm showing
this game and one of the reasons why
this game came to mind recently is I
play the classical tournament a few
weeks ago in Norway and I had a very
similar game I believe it was my round
six game I was playing against an FM and
I'll just show the position I had in
that game real quick I had this position
against FM Olay Christian Moen and um
when I played Queen D3 in that game I
was instantly reminded of the morphe
game and uh yeah it brought back some
some nice memories some Nostalgia of of
learning the classics now the difference
between my game and morphe's game morphe
had a rook on E6 and Pawn on B5 so a few
extra Tempe and in in this game I I
didn't really manage to get much of an
edge and I actually ended up plundering
my queen later so if you want to see the
whole analysis uh feel free to check the
link in the description
but we're gonna see morphe maybe a small
spoiler but rather than blundering his
Queen he's eventually going to sack the
queen in a brilliant fashion I guess a
spoiler is already above my head but
Queen D3
um enables black to start Pawling on the
pressure against whites white played
pawns a B4 Bishop drops back Pawn A4 now
Black Ops be careful A5 is a threat to
trap the bishop so Blackberry simply
takes after Queen A4 Bishop D7 not only
defending the C6 Pawn but also allowing
The Rook to get into play
and here white played kind of a
mysterious move Rook to A2 and when I
was reviewing the scheme I was trying to
understand like why would white go for
such a strange move but the point is to
play Queen C2 and try and just chase
away the queen from D3 and then
eventually get in D4 and live happily
ever after but the problem with Rook A2
is it's a little bit slow and black can
already start drumming up some nasty
attack and initiative and the move that
morphe played is very simple here rooked
E8 but it has a very deadly threat to it
where if white is negligent and plays
Queen C2
feel free to pause the video if you
don't see the move already but this is
black to move find the force mates made
in two move would be Queen takes off one
oh no my queen but then rookie won
checkmates so white has to be extremely
careful with uh Rook battery and the
Queen on D3 Queen takes F1 is a major
threat and H3 doesn't really help
because still Queen F1 and rookie one
mates so white came up with a clever
defensive idea here Queen to A6 making
it so if Queen takes f1 light can take
back with a queen and there's no Force
mate for black here
now in this position it is a critical
moment because the Queen's attacked and
it's a question how black can proceed
and I was reading the the annotations of
this game uh there's some brief
annotations on chess games.com and I
transferred it to Alicia study which I
will link below if you want to analyze
this game on your own but um there was a
comment from chernov who annotated the
game and he said that morphe took 12
minutes on his next move
so I do encourage viewers if you want to
pause the video maybe not for 12 minutes
but uh try and think in this position
and find the best move for black and I
will say that next move is one of the
reasons why I'm showing this game
absolutely brilliant and without further
Ado move is Queen takes F3 it's hacking
the queen for a bishop but completely
busting open the white king side and
when you play this move you really have
to calculate until the very end because
if you're going to sack the queen you
have to be sure that it's winning and
unfortunately for white there's not much
else but to play into the queen sack
after Pawn takes Queen the forcing moves
begin to flow Rook G6 check forcing the
king into the corner and then Bishop to
H3 and even though this isn't a directly
forcing move like it's not a check it is
threatening made in two with Bishop to
G2 and then King G1 Bishop takes F3
check needs and white is very very short
on defenses here given that the bishop
rook and queen are completely out of
play and a move like Rook G1 just fails
to Rook takes rook and then rookie one
and it's mating eventually so white did
manage to try and fight with the move
Rook to D1 but now we see kind of a mini
windmill blackface Bishop G2 King G1
Bishop takes F3 discover check forcing
the king to F1 and morphe I think maybe
kind of tortured his opponent a little
bit move back to G2 the most efficient
way to win here would have been Rook to
G2 with eventual Rook takes F2 and
there's boundless mating ideas but uh
Bishop G2 was played and after King G1
Bishop H3 forcing the king back and then
Bishop takes F2 and yeah in some sense
maybe morphy is playing with his food
but is also threatening Checkmate in one
and white had to give back a lot of the
material Queen F1 was played and after
takes takes rookie to the position does
not get easier for whites a few more
moves were played Rook A1 Rook H6 D4
Bishop E3 uh White actually resigned in
this position given that there's an
Unstoppable mating attack against H2
Bishop takes E3 doesn't help because
Rogue H2 and Rogue G2 checkmates
so it was an absolutely brilliant game
for morphe and the play really flowed
nicely out of the opening especially
with the key move Queen to D3 if we just
highlight
on sometimes the most effective way of
pressuring your opponent is restricting
what they want to do and restricting
their development and morphe did just
that in this game so I really hope you
guys enjoyed this one it is one of my
favorite morphe games if there are any
other morphe games that you think would
compete for morphe's greatest Queen
sacrifice feel free to let me know but I
do hope you stay tuned for more content
like this I do plan to share more of my
favorite games games that I think
everyone should know so be sure to
subscribe and I'll see you guys in a
future video